The Joe Rogan experience and it helped me actually develop this one piece that I
was doing and that be like sort of around it rounded out this one piece I was
doing because I was trying to figure out a way that I could explain it to
someone who might have a preconceived notion about who I am,
like the,
to to say it in a way that makes people that were hesitant,
laugh,
you know what I mean?
Versus savages at 1130 on a Saturday night that are hammered [inaudible] yeah.
So Whitney Cummings crowd wasn't a into your antifeminist laughed.
They laughed because the punchline was good and I,
I had a place to go with it and the place to go was ultimately mocking men's
rights activists.
That was the,
the,
the real thing was the,
this,
the setup for that joke is,
I don't like anybody's into one thing and I go,
but what tries to be the most fucking crazy is men's rights activists.
Like every men's rights activists I ever met.
I just want to grab them and go,
dude,
we got them all.
Yeah.
We've got all the rights.
Yeah,
we got them all.
I can't believe that's a real thing.
Men's rights activists.
What's a real thing?
If you get divorced and you have child,
uh,
it's a for child custody,
those things or do those things are real.
Like guys really,
I know men who have gotten really fucked over in divorce where their wife hired
a fucking killer lawyer and they drag them through.
See the thing about,
and I learned this from Phil Hartman,
unfortunately before he died,
uh,
I was trying to tell him to get divorced and I said,
just give her half man,
you'll make more money.
He goes,
it's not half.
it's two thirds.
He goes to fucking lawyers,
take a third.
It's got damn scam.
You know,
he like,
he was furious about it because apparently he had been trying to figure it out,
like how to do it.
But I had a friend whose wife,
ex wife dragged it out on purpose because she wanted him to pay the legal bills.
So he had to pay for her lawyer.
He had a pay for his lawyer and then he had to pay for all of the Times that she
decided to change the goal posts and mu and renegotiate like just no,
no one can say that you can't renegotiate.
So she would just renegotiate and just drag things out.
And her,
her goal was to try to drain him financially.
So she was doing this on purpose,
like targeting.
So he was essentially paying for the general of the army that was plotting to
murder him.
And he was slowly going crazy and I was watching my friend go crazy and it took
several years for it to be completely resolved and he's still paying her,
he's still,
he's been divorced for I think 12 years now and he still pays her.
She,
they didn't have a child.
Um,
and he has a family now.
He's married with children now.
He,
and he still pays this person still pay.
Like he fucked her so hard.
She can't work 12 years later.
Yeah,
it's so that's where men's rights activists have a point because if you're in a
state that's particularly a progressive or liberal in regards to alimony and
child support,
the only love,
the only thing that we win on that,
it's like Tom Arnold,
like we got one on the board for Tom Arnold when he divorced,
but the problem with that is I love Roseanne more than I love Tom Arnold.
No offense Tom.
But I do,
you know,
so like it bothered me that Roseanne had to pay him like,
Bro,
get the fuck Outta here.
You can work like why?
How come when you with a successful person,
if that's successful person says fucking kick bricks.
Get out of here.
You have to pay them that that person has to pay the person they're getting rid
of.
Yeah.
What?
Oh,
he's used to her lifestyle.
What's that?
That that I'm used to.
It is a crazy thing.
Yeah.
It's the only thing that makes sense is childcare.
That makes sense.
Like,
Hey,
I'm,
this person is taking care of the children.
They're your children.
You guys had these children together.
You have to contribute to the,
the,
the money that it costs to raise a child.
100% I get it.
What would I don't get his alimony.
I just don't get it.
We're not together anymore.
No.
How we were before we were together and you didn't have any money and then you
met me and now I have money and then you,
you got used to having money.
What?
You're going to have to get used to not having money because now you don't have
any money because now we're not together anymore.
Or like a year maybe.
You know what I mean?
Like,
Hey,
let her take some time to get back on her feet.
Right.
But a prostitute or anything.
Yeah.
You don't have to be,
and it's just bitterness.
It's like,
I want to take you for everything that I can.
One of my friends who's going through divorce,
he was like,
all my friends who've gotten a divorce,
I mean 80% of them,
if they have kids,
the wife accuses the husband of molesting the kids.
Oh,
Jesus.
Just for visitation,
you know,
just to like put negotiation with.
Yeah,
exactly.
Well,
the lawyers are onto that now.
You know,
I mean,
this is actually something that my friend was warned of when the him,
him and his wife were splitting up like,
is your wife malicious?
Will she,
you know,
make some sort of a baseless accusation?
And he's like,
how so?
And then they went into that.
Yeah,
man,
there's evil people out there that,
and there's also this thing that happens when people break up with someone.
If someone who doesn't want to be with you anymore,
someone that you deeply loved and cared about,
you want them to suffer.
It's weird.
I mean,
it's normal.
So I guess it's not that weird,
but the,
the evil,
vicious jealousy.